now there's this idea that there's a
there's the possibility of opening up a
line of communication between the human
psyche and the transcendent divine and
there's a there's a great image of
Christ as panik there so creator of the
world that just one of the first mosaics
if I remember correctly and I wish I
knew remember where it was but I don't
but it's a very interesting image I'm
having a carving of it made at the
moment by a friend of mine but you see
Christ's face portrayed in a medieval
manner and he's holding a book so it
symbolizes the importance of the book
you know as a means of transmitting
wisdom and his face is very asymmetrical
and that the eyes are different one side
and the other and one half of the face
represents the human part and the other
side of the face represents the divine
part and you know I also think about
that psychologically because I do think
that that's the right way to
conceptualize human beings is that
there's an aspect of us that's mortal
and human and limited but there's an
aspect of us that's transcendent and
divine as well and it's latent in some
sense but there are times when it
manifests itself and this is not
speculation right this is like the
oldest experience of human beings now
it's not necessarily an easy experience
to have but it's reported everywhere and
it can be reliably induced as we've
discussed before by chemical means which
and I don't know what that means exactly
we've talked a little bit about
psilocybin mushrooms for example and you
could say that the mystical experiences
that have been invoked in the newest
experiments down at Johns Hopkins are
arrangements or forms of psychosis you
know because they have some similarity
to psycho psychotic experiences although
psychotic people were given LSD in the
60s and they always said that that was
something different than what they were
having and if you give psychotic people
and fetta means you could make them
worse so they're biochemically separate
and and we know that and but also the
thing that's so interesting about the
psilocybin experience is is that they
reliably produce mystical experiences
that the people rate as among the most
important experiences of their life and
among those who have the psychedelic
experience
positive things happen to them and so
that kind of messes with the whole
psychosis theory right because what are
you gonna do you get a claim that you
give someone a pill and they have a
psychotic break and then they're
healthier it's like no that isn't how
psychotic breaks work you're not healthy
or after having one you're like you're a
broken egg and it's not easy to put you
back together so and we know that people
all over the world have discovered every
manner of psychedelic substance that you
could possibly while you imagine there's
lots of hungry people wandering the
earth for a long time and they ate every
damn thing they could get their hands on
and now and then something very peculiar
happened as a consequence so so I'm
gonna tell you a little bit about the
shamanic tradition because it's
associated with Jacob's Ladder so
according to Elliot
Mircea Eliade it was a great historian
of religion a comparative Jung's and and
and they influenced each other quite
substantially Eliana believed that
shamanism that used psychedelics was a
degeneration from the original more pure
shamanism but I think later scholarship
has demonstrated that that's incorrect
that that the shamanic ritual per se was
a direct consequence of the use
discovery of an and ritualistic use of
psychedelic substances but anyways
Eliana identified three pathways to
shamanism and the shaman in it in a
tribe was more educated than the typical
person with a larger vocabulary and was
the repository of the oral tradition and
so learned all the stories that had been
passed down word to mouth and people by
the way are very very can very very
accurately tell the same story across
generations that's been quite well
documented so and and people who can't
read really can remember because what
else are they going to do their memories
are far greater than modern people's
memories cuz we can forget everything
because we can just look it up but they
remembered things because they had no
choice my father knew someone who was
illiterate and and and couldn't use
numbers either when he grew up in
Saskatchewan you know 60 years ago and
he was a
he had a sheep if I remember correctly
and although he couldn't count he knew
if one of his sheep was missing because
he knew all the sheep and so he could
tell just by looking if one of the sheep
was missing but he couldn't count and so
well so people who don't have our
particular set of skills
first of all they're not stupid and
second they have other skills that we
don't understand to fill in the gaps
so a leotta identified spontaneous
vocation so you were just you have this
spirit of a shaman let's say so you're
probably extremely high and openness
let's say from a modern perspective
hereditary transmission so you know your
father was a shaman and your grandfather
was a shaman and so forth and you got
initiated into that process or a
personal quest in Siberia this is from a
Liana in Siberia the youth who is called
to be a shaman attracts attention by his
strange behavior for example he seeks
solitude becomes absent-minded loves to
roam in the woods or unfrequented places
has visions and sings in his sleep you
know if you put someone in a place
that's deprived that's where you're
you're deprived from a sensory
perspective it normal people will
hallucinate quite quickly so it seems
what happens is that if you dampen down
the sensory input then you start to
become aware of the background processes
of your mind it's something like that
it's like the signal-to-noise ratio I
gotta get this right as the noise
decreases some of the noise becomes
signal the background noise become
signal and you start to become aware of
your own internal psychological
processes it's something like that
he has visions and sings in his sleep in
some instances this period of incubation
is marked by quite serious symptoms
among the accout the young man sometimes
has fits of fury and easily loses
consciousness hides in the forest feeds
on the bark of trees throws himself into
water and fire and cuts themselves with
knives we went to a part lash in
northern northern Vancouver Island about
a year ago and they had this one dance
it was the croc waka wa natives and they
had this interesting dance that was the
dance of the wild man and so the person
who invited us was the wild man and he
was dressed up and in tree branches and
so forth and so he was the person who'd
been in the bush too long and he came in
as a cannibal
there there was genuine cannibalistic
rights among these people not so long
ago and he came in as a cannibal and
everybody had to wear this like cedar
headdress because if you had a cedar
headdress on then the cannibal wouldn't
take a bite out of you and they actually
took this rather seriously so you should
have your cedar headdress on and so he's
looking around the crowd and there's
like 400 people in this place and he
could really Achtung so he's doing this
wild man dance and then all the women
stood up and started to kind of dance in
place and sing and they were taming him
so that was really cool you know it was
really interesting to see that because
those people are about they've had an
unbroken culture for about 13,000 years
say that's how long they've been out
Island and it was very interesting to
see that dramatization of the
domestication of of man by women laid
out in that dance in that way but it was
also interesting in relationship to the
shamanic tradition because he came in as
a wild man right and he had to be re
civilized in some sense and brought back
down to earth so but by whatever method
he may have been designated as shaman is
recognized as such only after having
received two methods of instruction the
first is ecstatic dreams trances visions
the other thing that this guy told me
and and I have no reason to doubt him
he's also not a literate person and so
has a great memory he does carving
traditional carving and he's very good
at it he carved a 53-foot totem pole
that's now in front of the Museum of Art
in in downtown Montreal so if you ever
go there you can go see it I won't be
there forever but it's there right now
and he was taught to carve by his
grandparents and he said that he dreamed
in you know you know what the Haida
images look like so the Crocker walks
are kind of like the Haida same sort of
imagery he told me that he dreamed in
those images so when he dreams that's
the form that the things he dreams about
takes and he also said that he would
talk to his grandparents in his dream so
if he was working on a piece of wood and
trying to figure out how to carve it and
he ran into a particularly difficult
problem he dream and his great he'd have
a conversation with his grandparents and
they'd help him figure out how to solve
the problem and then he'd wake up and he
could go carve
and the thing is he told me these things
sort of matter-of-factly right like you
don't you know what I mean it wasn't
like he was telling me these weird
things that happened to him although he
was doing that to some degree he I asked
him a lot of questions about what he
carved and what it all meant and you
know that was just part of his
explanation of how he did it and he he
carved me a couple of doors that I have
in my house and one of them is quite
interesting well the to make a panel and
they're an underwater seat and under the
water there's a bunch of you know
mythical monsters some of them are
killer whales and I think there's an
octopus down there and carved in this
particular style and he said that the
other thing that happens to him when he
dreams is he goes down to the bottom of
the water where these mythical creatures
are and he gets inspiration from them
and so I thought that was extremely
interesting too you know we we don't
know what a mind that isn't hyper
civilized let's say hyper literate like
like our minds are because we're so
bombarded by external stimuli we have no
idea what the natural mind is like
really and so it was quite interesting
to to to listen to that and also to see
the consequences cuz he's quite a great
he's quite a great Carver so the first
is ecstatic dreams trances visions the
second is traditional shamanic
techniques names and functions of the
spirits mythology and genealogy of the
clan a secret language this twofold
teaching imparted by the spirits and the
old master shamans constitutes
initiation well so you know modern
people have a problem with that because
we don't really get initiated but I
would say that you know let's say that
we reach out a quest of some sort you
wouldn't be here I don't think if you
weren't because why else would you be
here and so you're on a quest of some
sort to figure out to struggle with the
meaning of life let's say and you don't
want to do that alone because you only
last like 70 years and good luck
figuring it out on your on your own it's
just not gonna happen it's too
complicated and you'll be too isolated
right if it's just you that's insanity
that's no one can stand that and so you
hope that other people
have things to tell you and that your
culture has something to tell you you
know so you're on a quest maybe not with
the same intensity as a shamanic
initiate but you know let's give you
some credit and then you're also trying
to understand the wisdom of the past and
that's the second part of this it's like
okay well you're a human being and human
beings have been telling stories for a
long period of time
trying to figure out what's going on
trying to figure out how to orient
themselves in the world and so you know
partly what you're doing here is exactly
what the shamanic initiative in the
second part of the process which is to
expose yourself to the degree that you
can too names and functions of the
spirits mythology and genealogy of the
clan and the secret language this
twofold teaching imparted by the spirits
and the old master shamans constitutes
initiation so it's that's a rebirth
right yeah that's that's what a
initiation is it's being born again and
and that's a birth of the spirit rather
than over the body it's something like
that and so it's the rebirth of an
integrated psyche that's one way of
thinking about it and a psyche that's
that's individual but also grounded in
common humanity and the wisdom of common
humanity and that makes you strong or at
least it makes you stronger